on a renforcé le dispositif qui permet
de lutter contre les trafics il y avait
une question simplement de répondre à
une actualité c'est à dire que du jour
au lendemain les doigts n'allait perdre
leur pouvoir d'aller faire des contrôles
puis s'il n'y avait pas eu de texte qui
concernaient les douanes depuis plus
d'un demi-siècle ça a été aussi
l'occasion de venir leur donner les
moyens de lutter contre la
sophistication j'ai envie de dire
grandissante des trafics en tout genre a
permis quand même beaucoup d'évolution
qui répondent véritablement aux enjeux
d'aujourd'hui il faut que la loi soit en
mesure de mettre fin aux agissements des
criminels qui eux utilisent tous les
artifices qu'ils ont pour pouvoir faire
leurs méfaits on voit aussi qu'il s'agit
de sécuriser leurs actions des
amendements aussi ont été portés par
Christophe Blanchet et qui sont venus
par exemple faciliter la participation à
la réserve douanière qui va être créée
par ce texte opérationnelle qui
permettra aux citoyens qui veulent
s'engager de pouvoir s'engager aussi
dans les douanes s'il le souhaite
jusqu'à 30 jours par an ou des retraités
douaniers de devenir les services pour
un moment donné permettre aux données
d'être en force sur des actions
ponctuelles les douanes étaient la seule
institution qui n'avait pas de réserve
on a aussi des dispositions qui
renforcent la lutte contre la
contrefaçon et notamment la vente en
ligne pour là aussi sécuriser les
dispositifs donc il fallait permettre
aux douanes de pouvoir s'adapter au
monde réel d'aujourd'hui ce projet de
loi va véritablement donner des moyens
supplémentaires et sans doute inspirer
aussi d'autres juridictions pour aller
encore plus loin l'année dernière les
douanes ont saisi 11,5 millions d'objets
contrefaits et deux tiers de ces objets
étaient des jeux et joués pour enfants
mais il faut continuer à donner les
moyens aux douanes pour protéger ne
serait-ce que un minimum nos enfants
concrètement il y a pas de grande
modification pour pour les français par
contre pour pour les malfrats pour les
voyous pour les trafiquants et bien oui
ça va changer puisque on a renforcé le
dispositif qui permet de lutter contre
les trafics
[Musique]